Hallo zusammen!
Wir machen heute Cookie Dough, also essbaren Keksteig ohne rohe Eier.
Und ihr könnt aus meinem Basic-Rezept heute 1000 Varianten machen!
Ich glaub ich zeig euch heute 3 Varianten. Vielleicht auch mehr, mal schauen!
Cookie Dough ist ja eigentlich so ein Trend aus Amerika..
In meinen Augen ist es gar kein Trend mehr, sondern ein Grundnahrungsmittel!
Also, wir fangen jetzt direkt mal an! Wir können beim Cookie Dough kein Mehl einfach als solches benutzen.
Das ist jetzt hier ganz normales Mehl Type 405, wir müssen das aber vorher einmal erhitzen/erwärmen.
Ich mache das im Backofen. Das dient einfach dazu, dass man so ein bisschen die Bakterien abtötet,
das ist ja strenggenommen ein Naturprodukt. Und dafür mache ich das jetzt so:
Ich nehm mir mein Backblech, geb da einfach das Mehl drauf, verteile das so ein bisschen..
Ihr könnt das übrigens auch in der Pfanne machen, einfach eine beschichtete Pfanne nehmen.
So!
(H: Können wir kurz darüber reden, wie braun du bist?!)
Ich?
(H: *lacht* Ja!)
Okay, wir waren im Urlaub! Wir kommen frisch aus dem Urlaub
und danach waren wir in der Türkei für unsere Haselnusscreme. Dazu gibt's auch bald ein extra Video!
Von daher... Hamza ist hinter der Kamera aber auch ziemlich braun!
So!
Und das gebe ich jetzt in den Backofen bei 170° C Ober- und Unterhitze, da reichen echt so 10-11min.
Das Mehl nimmt auf jeden Fall eine andere Farbe an, nicht wundern!
Das geben wir aber bis zum Auskühlen an die Seite.
Und jetzt machen wir weiter mit den anderen Zutaten. Ich habe jetzt hier Butter.
Wichtig ist, dass ihr die Butter erhitzt. Das habe ich jetzt in der Mikrowelle gemacht,
geringe Wattzahl, sonst platzt die euch und die ganze Mikrowelle ist schmutzig!
Und ganz ganz wichtig ist, dass ihr die Butter bitte auskühlen lasst.
Die gebe ich jetzt hier meine Schüssel und anschließend gebt ihr Zucker dazu.
Und beim Zucker ist es so, dass ich eine Mischung aus weißem Zucker und braunem Rohrzucker nehme.
Und dann gebt ihr noch von meinem Vanilleextrakt dazu, das gibt dem Ganzen so eine gewisse Grundnote
und dann schmeckt euer Cookie Dough / euer Teig auch nicht nur nach Zucker pur.
Und ich finde auch gerade das Gemisch zwischen weißem und braunem Zucker,
das hat dann auch wieder so eine karamellige Note.
Wenn ihr nur pur weißen Zucker nehmen würdet, dann wäre das so ein bisschen pappig.
Also ich finde das ist einfach dieses Feine, was ihr dann am Ende raus schmecken werdet.
Und falls ihr euch wundert - das ist mir auch wichtig, zu sagen - warum die Butter abgekühlt sein soll:
Ich möchte nicht, dass die Zuckerkristalle sich darin sofort auflösen
und die Konsistenz verändert sich ansonsten.
Also die Konsistenz so ist perfekt. Hamza kannst du da noch mal nah rangehen?
(H: Du bist ja richtige Chemikerin, hab gar keine Ahnung was du laberst!)
Hier, ich hab ganz oft schon Cookie Dough ausprobiert und die Rezeptur gefällt mir am besten.
So und jetzt kommt das abgekühlte Mehl zum Einsatz.
Ich siebe das Ganze nochmal weil auch hier noch ganz kleine Stückchen drin sind
und ich möchte die eben nicht da drin haben.
Also einmal noch mit dazu sieben.
Und die ganz genauen Mengenangaben - oh Gott, oh Gott, gar nicht gesagt! -
findet ihr unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Jetzt habe ich alles miteinander verrührt und mit dem Kochlöffel funktioniert das einfach besser
weil die Masse ist schon sehr...
(H: Was willst du grad sagen? Was?)
Also nicht kompakt, sondern...
(H: Klebrig.)
Klebrig definitiv aber halt auch sehr...
(H: Fest.)
Wuchtig! So haben wir's jetzt auch mal!
So und da gebe ich jetzt einen Schluck Milch rein.
So, nur ein bisschen..
Und ihr werdet selber merken, wie die Konsistenz ist, wie sie euch am besten gefällt..
Ich werde das Ganze gleich auch noch mal für 15min  in den Kühlschrank tun
damit auch noch mal alles richtig schön ziehen kann
Also nach 15min im Kühlschrank ist die Konsistenz schon echt anders,
daher gebt die Milch auf jeden Fall dazu.
Auch ich hatte als ich das Rezept hin und her getestet habe Bedenken:
"Soll ich jetzt noch Milch dazu tun oder nicht?"
Aber Milch in Kombination mit dem Mehl ergibt dann schon wieder eine ganz andere Konsistenz
aber es braucht dann halt eben kurze Kühlschrankzeit.
So und jetzt teile ich meinen Teig auf und zwar in 3 Portionen
denn ich möchte 3 verschiedene Varianten machen. Und grundsätzlich könnt ihr ja
unendlich viele Variationen machen.
Schreibt mir dafür einfach mal in die Kommentare was für Variationen ihr noch kennt,
was ihr mögt. Vielleicht kann ich ja noch ein zweites Video machen
mit z.B. 10 weiteren Cookie Dough Varianten.
Ich bin mir übrigens nicht sicher, ob es Cookie Dough oder Cookie Doo oder Cookie Dogh heißt!
(H: Cookie Doof!)
Cookie Doof!
So, jetzt habe ich den ersten Cookie Dough mit weißem Schokoladenstückchen getoppt
den zweiten mit ganz schönen bunten Streuseln und den dritten mit Oreos und Vollmilch-Chunks.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, welchen ich jetzt als erstes probieren soll!
Ich probier jetzt einfach mal meinen persönlichen Favoriten und zwar den mit den Vollmilch-Chunks!
Und das riecht schon so gut. Das riecht einfach so so gut!
(H: Ich hab in meinem Leben noch nie Cookie Dough probiert!)
Nein ehrlich?
(H: Ja ich dachte das wird noch gebacken oder so!)
Ja der Hamza sagt gerade allen Ernstes: "Und jetzt Ofen vorheizen?" Ich so: "Nein?"
Boah! Sehr geil.
(H: Ehrliche Meinung! Sei mal ganz ehrlich.)
Okay!
Es schmeckt so, als hätte man jetzt einen Teig vorbereitet, der in den Ofen wandern muss!
Das heißt es schmeckt so ehrlich. Es schmeckt so ehrlich!
(H: Also es schmeckt halt so wie wenn Mama backt früher und ich dann bevor sie den Teig in den Ofen packt
ich nasche?)
Genau und du einmal naschst!
Und am Ende die Reste, genauso schmeckt das!
(H: Geil, ich liebe sowas!)
Richtig richtig gut, natürlich, nicht künstlich - einfach nur ein Traum!
Macht das unbedingt nach, ihr werdet es nicht bereuen!
Und schreibt mir unbedingt in die Kommentare die weiteren Möglichkeiten.
Ich möchte gern ein zweites Video dazu machen
und dann einfach mal verschiedene
crazy Möglichkeiten ausprobieren wie Salted Caramel
(H: *kichert* Haselnusscreme!)
Haselnusscreme!
Also ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen! Vergesst nicht, diesem Video ein Däumchen nach oben da zu lassen
und unbedingt ein kostenloses Abo hier unten! Und dann sehen wir uns bei meinem nächsten Rezeptvideo.
Tschüss, eure Kiki!